bonjour thierry amouroux merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france le ministre de la santé
promet donc ce matin dans les colonnes
du journal du dimanche d'augmenter les
rémunérations
du côté de l'hôpital public ils
s'engagent également assouplir les 35
heures chez les soignants comment est-ce
que vous accueillez ces annonces à bain
avec beaucoup d'espoir concernant les
rémunérations parce que jusqu'à présent
il n'y a pas grand chose il faut bien
comprendre que les soignants français
sont sous payés par rapport à la moyenne
européenne par exemple sur les
infirmières ses 300 euros 2,2 moins que
le salaire moyen en europe pour les
infirmiers donc il ya beaucoup de retard
a récupéré la cette semaine y ait eu la
petite prime donc cette prime pour la
grosse majorité des soignants dans 60
départements
elle ne sera que de 500 euros pour 40
autres départements elle atteindra 1500
euros et puis bien il ya les héros à
zéro euro
ceux qui sont dans le secteur privé dans
le secteur libéral
les intérimaires et les vacataires sont
venus dans les hôpitaux qui eux ont
juste droit à une médaille en chocolat
justement parlant de cette prime
qu'ovide qui devrait arriver sur la paye
à la fin mai ce que demandent les
soignants c'est donc une revalorisation
des salaires une reconnaissance de leur
de leur métier en pleine crise je vous
propose cette citation d'olivier ferrand
je cite il faudra qu'on mobilise de
l'argent nouveau pour augmenter les
rémunérations
quelle enveloppe faudra-t-il selon vous
on sait que sa prédécesseure agnès buzyn
avait annoncé 1 5 milliard d'euros sur
trois ans alors elle ne lui dis avait
annoncé cette cette somme mais pas pour
les revalorisations salariales eu plus
pour l'achat de matériel agir également
sur eux sur la tête de l'hôpital
voilà enfin où on est content que enfin
on s'intéresse aux salaires il ya aussi
un grand plan sur l'hôpital qui est
nécessaire pour ouvrir des lits on a 20
% des délits en france 100 milles sur 20
ans et on a bien vu le décalage qu'il y
avait entre la france et l'allemagne la
france n'ayant que 5000 lits de
réanimation l'allemagne than sami 5 fois
plus
alors qu'ils sont pas réputés pour jeter
l'argent par les fenêtres donc on voit
bien qu'il y avait un vrai décalage sur
les lits sur les postes aussi à l'ap-hp
3500 postes ont été supprimés en quatre
ans donc voilà il faut on est des moyens
pour répondre aux besoins de santé de la
population dont il faut ouvrir des lits
créer des postes ça c'est cet
indispensable de parler de l'allemagne
beaucoup de français un penser avant le
meilleur système de santé au monde à
voir avec la crosse du coronavirus on se
rend compte que beaucoup de pays dont
l'allemagne ont fait mieux comment
est-ce que vous l'expliquer beaucoup
dénoncent eux une bureaucratie
hospitalière trop importante trop de
couches administratives et pas
suffisamment de proximité avec les
patients à ce que c'est votre avis
également tout à fait créer la
technostructure non seulement a été
incapable de gérer la crise heureusement
qu'il y avait des professionnels de
terrain pour compenser leur manque mais
nous en tant que soignant non seulement
nous
vendu gérer l'épidémie mais aussi gérer
les manques léman que de masquer de
surblouse le manque de test le manque de
lits le manque de respirateurs et à côté
de ça mais la texture structures non
seulement a été incapable de gérer mais
elle nous aussi empoisonné la vie
je prends pour exemple ben les cliniques
privées qui avaient libéré 5000 y est on
a perdu 15 joue avant que les ars se
décide à envoyer des patients dans ses
livres pendant quinze jours dans les
clips river alors que nous dans les
hôpitaux publics ont été débordés dans
le grand est et en ile de france
également le convoi sanitaire entre le
chu de reims et celui de tours qui a été
obligé de faire demi tour parce qu'un
bureaucrate a estimé qu'ils avaient pas
le tampon bon endroit où tous ses
laboratoires de médecine
environnementale et les terrines air des
laboratoires publics dépendant des des
conseils départementaux de l'état qui se
proposait pour produire fournir 150
militaires par semaine et qui ne sont
toujours pas utilisé a fallu trois
semaines pour que le mini se décide à
donner l'autorisation et mais depuis un
mois il ya encore que la bureaucratie
qui bloque le parcours pour les empêcher
de produire alors que la france ne
produit que 150000 test cette semaine
elle pourra en produire le double si on
faisait appel à ces laboratoires pour
parler de vous couper vous pouvez parler
de test justement il ya une polémique
ces derniers jours avec le
service enquêtes de radio france
notamment qui évoque un million de tests
commandés à la chine qui attendrait
qu'il ne serait pas qui ne
fonctionnerait pas qu'en est il à propos
de cela est-ce que vous avez des
informations
malheureusement on dit on voit bien
qu'on a une équipe de des branquignols
quoi c'est à dire que la sueur cj
cuvillon ils ont commandé n'importe quoi
la même chose pour les respirateurs vous
savez les fameux 10000 respirateur
commandée par l'état
8500 de ses 10000 respirateur ne sont
totalement pas adapté à la gestion de
patients en réanimation et peuvent juste
permettre de faire du transport de sa
mue et pendant deux trois heures donc on
voit bien qu'il ya un vrai problème et
nous nous sommes pour la fermeture des
agences régionales de santé qui ont été
créés il ya dix ans qui ont fait leur
preuve de leur inefficacité
pendant la crise et qui au quotidien
depuis dix ans ne sont là que pour
fermer des lits et supprimer des postes
des services d'urgence de la maternité
etc
donc voilà il faut revoir ce système de
des bureaucraties inutile il ya onze ni
le fonctionnaire au ministère de la
santé payé très cher on est cadre a
chargé de mission etc y aurait de quoi
créer des milliers de postes
d'infirmières ou d'ex régnante dans les
hôpitaux en supprimant un peu tout ce
qui est superflu
dernière question rapidement on sait que
jeudi à une manifestation d'aidé
soignant à l'hôpital michel debré à
paris vendredi matin deux soignantes ont
interpellé emmanuel macron à la pitié
salpêtrière
à quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre en
termes de mobilisation de la part du
secteur hospitalier après le rappel huit
mois de grève
c'était avant la crise sanitaire on
parle d'une manifestation peut être à la
mi juin vous confirmez oui bien entendu
il faut voir que depuis le déconfinement
ça explose dans beaucoup d'endroits il
ya eu
toulouse nantes nancy saint-etienne
saint nazaire
robert debré à l'ap-hp dont vous parliez
voilà les soignants non peuvent plus et
est donc voilà on est très en colère ont
fait moquer de nous ces derniers jours à
ses histoires de de don de rtt de chèque
cadeau de deux médailles en chocolat de
défiler au pas de l'oie le 14 juillet
manque juste la photo dédicacée
non on veut des moyens pour l'hôpital et
une revalorisation salariale
merci thierry amouroux ces mots de la
fin merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
porte parole du syndicat national des
professionnels infirmiers cn pays c'est
le pays pardon cfe cgc